sabemos que es una base [ __ ] normal pero
la pregunta obvia que nos brinca es y
para qué son buenas y una de las tantas
respuestas a esa pregunta es que
funcionan muy bien como existen sistemas
de coordenadas o bases coordenadas
entonces estos compadres aquí las bases
orton normales son buenos son buenos
sistemas
sistemas de coordenadas de coordenadas
ok entonces vamos a ver vamos a probar
por ejemplo nosotros conocemos muy bien
una base [ __ ] normal y que es la base
estándar de rn por ejemplo la base
estándar de rn la base estándar de rn es
decir la base canónica verdad es este
conjunto y lo voy a poner como vectores
digo podría llamarles como en muchos
otros vídeos 1 12 3 etcétera pero es el
conjunto de vectores donde el primero
tiene uno en la primera coordenada 0 en
las demás ok
este es nuestro primer vector donde
tenemos también el que tiene un 1 en la
segunda coordenada es cero en los demás
y así sucesivamente hasta el vector que
tiene todos ceros de poner bien
los límites tiene puros ceros y sólo un
1 al final
ok entonces esta es nuestra base
estándar de rn y podemos ver fácilmente
muy fácilmente que este es una base [ __ ]
normal y esto es claro por lo siguiente
tomamos cualquier vector por ejemplo
este de aquí y si multiplicamos si
hacemos producto punto de este consigo
mismo pues vamos a tener uno por uno que
es 1 y lo demás son ceros entonces su
norma al cuadrado es 1 y por lo tanto su
norma es 1 lo mismo va a pasar con con
el resto de los vectores ahora si nos
tomamos dos distintos por ejemplo estos
dos habrá muchos vector mucho muchas
coordenadas perdón en donde coincidan
los ceros pero siempre que haya un uno
en algún vector en la en el otro va a
haber un cero entonces eso hará que se
anulen lo mismo aquí por ejemplo tenemos
un 1 y acá un 0 y no importa cuál pareja
de vectores me tome esto va a ser cierto
para cualquiera para cualquiera 2
es que me tomé entonces en realidad este
es una base [ __ ] normal es decir la
norma de cada uno de estos es uno y son
ortogonales entre sí es decir el
producto punto entre ellos son es cero y
por lo tanto esto es algo que lo hace un
buen sistema o un buen sistema de
coordenadas ok esto es lo que lo hace un
buen sistema de coordenadas
y
de coordenadas y en si debo de mostrarte
ahorita por qué todas las bases [ __ ]
normales son buenas para sistemas de
coordenadas verdad entonces si por
ejemplo nos tomamos ve un conjunto b que
tiene vectores b1 b2
bueno vamos a poner y así sucesivamente
hasta beca ok y suponemos que esto es un
conjunto corto normal entonces esto ya
sabemos que es un conjunto linealmente
independiente verdad lo vimos en algún
vídeo anterior y entonces eso hace que
sea una base [ __ ] normal una base [ __ ]
normal de algún sub espacio ve de hecho
es el sub espacio generado por estos
vectores entonces la afirmación que
tenemos y que hay que hay que hay que
justificar es que este si es una base
[ __ ] normal es un buen sistema de
coordenadas y bueno uno puede decir que
algo es bueno oa lo mejor un amigo es
bueno pero pero tenemos que decir que
significa que algo sea bueno verdad este
puede ser bueno en muchos sentidos
entonces vamos a ir explorando esto
vamos a experimentar un poquito por
ejemplo si yo me tomo un vector x
en nuestro psuv espacio ve que si nos
tomamos un equis en este sub espacio
como éste sube espacio es el generado
por esto por estos vectores entonces x
lo podemos expresar como una combinación
lineal de estos es decir puedo expresar
lo como c 1 por b 1 es decir b 1 lo
multiplicó por algún c 1 más de 2 por b
2 y así sucesivamente voy sumando hasta
seca beca y déjenme poner ahí alguno
intermedio para que se vea un poquito
más en general sí y por vez más seca
beca ok entonces partiendo de esto vamos
a experimentar un poquito qué pasa si yo
hago la multiplicación de strike de esta
igualdad hago el producto punto con
alguno de estos vectores es decir qué
pasa si yo hago x
y déjenme multiplicar así b y punto x
qué pasa pues sería b y multiplicar por
toda esta suma verdad entonces tendremos
c 1 x de 1 punto b
más de dos dedos punto de iu
más
y por b y punto b y algunos de ustedes
ya entenderán por qué escribí este más
seca beca
punto y el secreto de todo esto es que
en realidad me tomé un beat arbitrario
es decir podría ser cualquiera de estos
vectores que se encuentran en mi
conjunto b podría ser b 1 podría ser b 2
en fin podría ser incluso beca el que
sea entonces cuál es la magia que
obtenemos en este en este en este
experimento que estamos haciendo como ve
es una base [ __ ] normal si yo me tomo
dos vectores distintos el producto punto
es cero porque es ortogonal verdad
entonces estos de aquí se hacen cero
porque estamos haciendo producto punto
de dos vectores distintos todos van a
ser cero excepto uno excepto en el cual
coincide en verdad entonces aquí tengo b
b y que eso es la norma debe y al
cuadrado y ahí volvemos a usar que es
una base [ __ ] normal y en particular que
está normalizado es decir que la norma
de todos estos es 1 entonces este de
aquí vale 1 y que es lo que obtenemos
que es lo que obtenemos obtenemos la
siguiente expresión que bay bay punto x
es igual
y verdad porque todos estos se anularon
el único que sobrevive es este que es
seguido por uno
entonces tenemos esta expresión y esta
expresión es sumamente valiosa es
sumamente valiosa tú dirás bueno este
llegamos a esto verdad empezamos a
experimentar que con las combinaciones
lineales llegamos a este resultado pero
él a lo mejor te preguntas pero para qué
demonios me va a servir y vamos a tratar
de recordar que era lo que hacíamos
cuando hacemos el cambio de los cambios
de base ok teníamos un vector equis y lo
queremos expresar en las coordenadas de
nuestro conjunto ve a ver si lo puedo
subir para que se vea muy bien entonces
esto esto lo podemos escribir esto no es
otra cosa más que el vector que tiene
como coordenadas estos coeficientes el
peso que le estoy dando a cada uno de
los vectores de mi base entonces éste
sólo un breve repaso de lo que ya hemos
hecho en otros vídeos y este vector está
definido por c1 c2
y
seca verdad es este vector
este vector de aquí y en general
encontrar encontrar estas constantes no
es fácil esto no es así tan trivial y
que uno lo puede hacer en dos minutos y
lo mejor el vector es muy grande porque
bueno sabemos que podríamos encontrarla
como comúnmente lo hacíamos era tu mamá
tomábamos el vector el vector en
cambiado en las coordenadas de nuestro
conjunto b de nuestra base b y decíamos
buenos y yo quiero escribir a x tengo
que multiplicar aquí por la matriz de
cambio de base y esto es lo que me va a
dar el vector x verdad entonces si
nosotros queremos encontrar quién es
este vector podríamos multiplicar por la
inversa de c y decir bueno pues tenemos
que el vector x expresada en las
coordenadas de la base b es igual hacia
la menos 1 por el vector x ahora esto
sólo es válido solo
si la matriz ce es invertible y en
general pues eso no tiene que ser cierto
verdad en general no necesariamente es
cierto que que sea invertirle entonces
este resultado es muy particular es muy
particular y no es tan útil como como si
tenemos una base [ __ ] normal y eso es
por lo siguiente porque estas estas
constantes este vector si tenemos una
base [ __ ] normal ya sabemos cómo
calcularlo me dice que si es igual a
punto equis entonces c 1 será igual a c
1 perdón b 1 punto x
aunque sé dos pues será de dos equis y
así sucesivamente hasta seca que va a
ser perdón seca
seca será beca punto equis y entonces
aquí tenemos ya una forma muy bonita y
muy sencilla de calcular quién es el
vector expresado en el sistema de
coordenadas b ok entonces vamos a hacer
ahora un ejemplo concreto para que veas
que esto aunque a lo mejor hasta aquí es
muy abstracto y muy complicado al menos
hacerlo es muy sencillo
entonces vamos a tomar los dos vectores
vamos a tomarnos el vector de uno
digamos que este vector sea el tres
quintos y en su segunda coordenada vamos
a ponerle que sea cuatro quintos muy
bien y vamos a tomarnos también el
vector de 2 que sea el que tiene
coordenadas menos cuatro quintos y 3
muy bien entonces vamos a hacer una
afirmación si nosotros nos tomamos el
conjunto b el que está formado por el
por los vectores b1 y b2
y b2 si tenemos este conjunto
la afirmación podría ser que este es un
conjunto [ __ ] normal entonces qué es lo
que tenemos que checar que es la norma
de estos dos vectores es 1 y que además
estos dos son ortogonales entre sí vamos
a verlo vamos a bajar un poco entonces
la norma del vector b 1 al cuadrado
vamos a ponerlo al cuadrado va a ser
igual a éste al cuadrado más éste al
cuadrado éste al cuadrado son 9 entre 25
más cuatro quintos al cuadrado son 16
sobre 25 916 son 25 y esto está dividido
entre 25 y esto es 1 entonces la norma
al cuadrado es 1 la norma sin el
cuadrado también es 1 ahora vamos a ver
quién es la norma debe 2 al cuadrado y
eso es menos cuatro quintos al cuadrado
eso es 16 sobre 25
tres quintos al cuadrado son nueve sobre
25 y 16 más 9 son 25 nuevamente tenemos
25 sobre 25 que es 1 entonces al menos
ya sabemos que este conjunto está
normalizado los dos vectores son
unitarios tienen norma 1 ok ahora lo
único que nos falta revisar que si
hacemos el producto punto debe 1 con de
esto nos debe dar 0 y b 1 el producto
punto es tres quintos por menos cuatro
quintos nos queda menos 12 sobre 25 y
ahora cuatro quintos por tres quintos es
más 12 sobre 25 que es esencialmente lo
mismo y por lo tanto es cero
así que este conjunto en efecto es un
conjunto conjunto corto normal por todo
normal es un conjunto corto normal muy
bien entonces de hecho son dos vectores
linealmente independientes entonces y
como tienen dos coordenadas esto
fácilmente lo podemos concluir como que
ve es una base es una base del espacio r
con una base del espacio r2 muy bien
entonces esto es porque tengo dos
vectores linealmente independientes y
por lo tanto generan a un espacio de dos
dimensiones que es el número de
coordenadas que tienen verdad entonces
vamos a hacer un ejemplo por ejemplo qué
tal si nos tomamos al vector no sé vamos
a tomarnos un vector cualquiera el 99
menos 2 vamos a tomarnos este este
vector 9 menos 2 entonces por lo que
hemos estado viendo nos interesa
encontrar cómo escribir este vector
en el sistema de coordenadas b entonces
sabemos que pues nuestros nuestra matriz
de cambio de variable pues es
esencialmente ésta la que tiene tres
quintos
dos menos cuatro quintos y tres quintos
que si esto lo multiplicamos por el
vector x en términos de la de la en el
sistema de coordenadas b eso me debe dar
el vector original que es 9 menos 2 y
entonces podríamos hacer lo que dijimos
acá arriba verdad podríamos encontrar la
matriz inversa y en resolver el sistema
en fin
lo más sencillo es utilizar esta
herramienta que ya encontramos porque
porque sabemos entonces que el vector x
escrito en el sistema de coordenadas b
pues no es otra cosa más que el producto
punto de estos dos vectores con el
vector x verdad entonces esto va a ser
de 1 punto x y de 2 punto x muy bien y
esto será igual vamos a hacer las
cuentas quienes ven 1 punto x de 1 punto
x es 9 por tres quintos que son 27
quintos y luego cuatro quintos por menos
dos son menos ocho quintos muy bien esto
por un lado ahora por el otro lado
quienes ve 2 punto x es menos cuatro
quintos por nueve son menos
9 x 4 son 36 quintos y tres quintos por
menos dos son menos seis quintos muy
bien entonces esto simplemente nos da 27
menos ocho son 19 son 19
19 quintos y acá abajo menos 36 quintos
menos 65 son menos cuarenta y dos
quintos muy bien
si las cuentas no salieron muy bien esto
no se está espero que puedas ver la
facilidad con lo que hicimos esto
y si tuviéramos un problema similar pero
que no estuviera en r2 que a lo mejor
estuviera de 4 n recién imagínate
calcular la inversa de una matriz o
resolver el sistema sería muy complicado
y sin embargo con esta técnica se vuelve
muy sencillo al inicio al inicio
estábamos hablando de que es escribir
las cosas en términos de una base [ __ ]
normal eran buenas y ya vimos cuál es
una de esas caras por las cuales son
buenas las bases [ __ ] normales verdad es
fácil encontrar coordenadas respecto a
bases [ __ ] normales